all of us in the concession community
feel like we're the victim of pretty
high stakes politics
I have been in the park and recreation
business for roughly 40 years and I've
run this company for 33 years our
company currently manages parks for city
agencies counties state and federal but
by far the largest portion of our
businesses campground concessions the
bulk of those are with US forest service
we do have one with the US Army Corps of
Engineers the federal shutdown has
affected all of the Forest Service
campgrounds but ironically dot the Corps
of Engineers Corps of Engineers
campground has remained open but we have
received direction from the Forest
Service to close all of our Forest
Service campgrounds the Forest Service
was moving to on a track to allow us to
remain open which was logical and they
they were derailed by someone higher and
I I don't think it was within the forest
service i think it was outside the
forest service it could have been within
the agriculture department and if not
the AG department it would have to be in
the White House but yeah I think all of
us in the concession community feel like
we're the victim of pretty high stakes
politics our relationship to the federal
government is were issued what's called
a special use permit essentially they
put all of the responsibility for the
day-to-day operations on the backs of
the private companies like my own and
it's essentially putting the campgrounds
on a user pays basis but we are far more
responsive to the public and their
desires and their needs because we have
to be then the government can be because
the government is insulated from that
and it's not their fault they just are
the national forests are not closed they
remain open and you can do what they
call dispersed camping which is where
you just go out in the woods and set up
anywhere on the National Forest in
what's what's kind of ironic is what
they closed were the developed sites
which were the ones that were staffed
and maintained by concessionaires or if
the Forest Service was doing it by
Forest Service staff during the last
shutdown back in Newt Gingrich's day
the government allowed the concession
campgrounds to remain open because
primarily our relationship is that of a
tenant to a landlord we actually pay the
government we do not receive funds from
the government and in those days the
reservation system was directly
contracted with the concessionaire
community so the concessionaires
actually were able to continue getting
reservations that's changed under the
new system under the new reservation
contract the government has got itself
in the middle of the contract so when
the government shutdown and all those
employees were furloughed it interrupted
the reservation service I personally do
not see any difference between now and
1995 except for the reservation service
they wanted to do it that way and they
went to a multi-agency approach I could
live with that and I could live without
reservations for a short period of time
but what I don't understand is how they
can close us when we're not dependent at
all upon appropriated funds it costs a
lot of money to close down a park and to
keep people out and I don't see the
point of that
you